[Música]
esta semana iniciamos cultura con un
reto estarían siete días solos en una
isla faro viendo 60 películas entrenadas
estamos serían unos 8 filmes al día el
desafío es llevar al extremo el encierro
a cortesía del festival sueco de
gotemburgo la propuesta real para una
única persona no es un capricho la
pandemia ha cambiado nuestra relación
con todo también con el cine dando
espacio a títulos de autor y ante una
edición tan peculiar el evento ha
querido experimentar no sólo estrenando
para alguien sin teléfonos sin libros
sino proyectando en su clásico cine
drake para invitados que de forma
individual vivirán una gala simbólica
con directores actores productores obvio
para el público general no faltará
versión en casa
en el cierro muchas personas buscaron
consuelo y compañía en las películas y
eso nos interesó mucho como la pandemia
ha cambiado nuestra relación con el cine
tengo mucha curiosidad sobre cómo esta
experiencia estar solo en una isla sin
teléfono ni ordenador ni siquiera un
libro afecta y cómo cambia la
experiencia de ver las 60 cintas del
festival la experiencia será diferente
esas cintas crearán diferentes emociones
en esas circunstancias y en what's your
in dos circunstancias si mis las
cinéfilas para todos aconsejamos que
entrar lo virtual
el streaming está superando en los
millones de abonados pueden verlo en
estas cifras de suscriptores que tienen
a netflix como líder global en parte con
éxitos como lee para gambito de dama
pero a este campo de batalla se suman
más universal plus en españa' y
paramount las en latinoamérica a partir
de marzo con estos añadidos
netflix va a lanzar una función
aleatoria que escogerá por nosotros que
ver el dilema si elegiría una cinta como
white night in miami de regina king kong
tal reflexión sobre el racismo y la fama
que no pesa saber qué es la ópera prima
de la actriz porque la respaldan amish
un oscar una gran dirección en series
tampoco que sea una dramaturgia de camps
hours cinematografía 2 porque su
planteamiento inspira y es que hubiera
ocurrido si la noche de 1964 en la que
mohamed alí se alzó boxeador del mundo
el y el activista malcom ex el cantante
shampoo y el deportista jean brown se
hubieran visto en florida eran amigos de
cassius pero ojalá se hubiese dado este
ring de cuarto de hotel esta interacción
entre cuatro hombres no exentos del
desprecio racial que los lleva a pensar
por su rol en la lucha por los derechos
civiles se dan golpes dialécticos surgen
diferencias pero que bien detonan es en
black power tan actual
de aseos
[Música]
en el barco
y repite la falsa
avilés
le tengo pena
nos retiramos del cuadrilátero por una
razón y es que la cinta hindú de white
tiger de rey min bailan y tumba en
mensaje a slumdog millionaire y esos
millones de rupias cuenta con algunas
exageraciones a cámaras si bien alcanza
la oscuridad y la provocación justas
para retratar la brutal diferencia de
clases en india es valdrán un joven de
pueblo que va a la ciudad para ser
chófer quien encarna el peso de la
injusticia y la ambición de ser un
hombre de dinero que no deba cargar con
más humillaciones el punto es que la
tragicomedia está servida así como están
dispuestos los caminos de la venganza
entre los actores
la reconocida brilla en catch obra
[Música]
llegar plancha
blanch
[Música]
ahora abre camino chicha el que expone
only one service generation
[Música]
la torta con más artistas
empezamos con una pregunta y añadimos
otras deben desterrarse ciertos libros
no prohibir los niveles ray bradbury
pero apartarlos de la venta por motivos
evidentes hablamos de un genocidio de
millones de personas ese veto siempre
está sobre mein kampf mi lucha el
manifiesto autobiográfico de adolf
hitler aun cuando sus derechos son
públicos pero en polonia esa crítica se
ha reabierto ante una edición académica
de precio asequible que pretende ser un
tributo a las víctimas y una advertencia
sobre el totalitarismo los contras son
las sensibilidades y el debate de si es
necesario acotar todo incluso el mal
evidente que puede tener un libro como
este los comentarios son bienvenidos
no podemos negar el hecho de que mein
kampf es una fuente histórica importante
aun cuando tenemos una opinión severa de
su contenido y de lo que conllevó en
alemania en 2016
apareció una edición crítica las ventas
superaron los 100.000 ejemplares y no
notamos un fenómeno condenables que
muestra un renacimiento de las
tendencias extremistas
y con mil yenes diciéndonos lo habíais
estado esperando ponemos fin a este
repaso y ya la intriga de oírla cantar
junto a rosalía porque la californiana
está en lo cierto tras anunciar esta
unión
hace dos años se anhelaba haber
aterrizado este lo vas a olvidar que
finalmente han creado juntas el tema no
sólo tira hacia la catalana sino que
para más deleite arropa la serie euforia
ya su segundo capítulo especial dedicado
a jules y a todas sus capas en relación
a rock disfruten de ambos dúos y gracias
por la compañía
qué notar
[Música]
sí
y yo la tengo
y yo
[Música]
i
si yo la tengo
[Música]
la vida